y nos dicen las cantidades xy son
proporcionales y nos dan una tabla con
diferentes valores de x y las
correspondientes y es cuando x 64 que es
10 cuando x 5 que es 12.5 y así
consecutivamente encuentra la constante
de proporcionalidad r en la ecuación que
igual a r por x entonces pausa en el
vídeo y vean si pueden resolver ok
queremos encontrar la constante de
proporcionalidad r en donde por cada x
al multiplicar la x r obtenemos un valor
de g
entonces vamos a analizar cada uno de
los valores de x y tratemos de calcular
por cual número necesitamos multiplicar
para obtener que en este caso por cual
número tenemos que multiplicar 4 para
obtener 10 bueno si multiplicamos por 10
cuartos obtenemos 10 y 10 cuartos es lo
mismo que cinco medios que es lo mismo
que multiplicar por dos y medio
tenemos dos y medio pero eso se aplica a
los demás si en cada caso multiplicamos
x por dos y medio obtenemos ese valor de
y vamos a ver si multiplicamos 5 por 2 y
medio 5 por 2 es 10 más la mitad de 5
que es 2.5 es igual a 12.5 entonces aquí
multiplicamos 5 por 2.5 y finalmente 10
por 2.5 es igual a 25 ustedes pueden
hacer todos los cálculos por escrito yo
lo hice mentalmente pero de cualquier
manera podemos ver que en cada caso
tomamos el valor de x lo multiplicamos
por 2.5 y obtenemos el valor de y
entonces si en cada caso tomamos x y la
multiplicamos por la constante de
proporcionalidad que es igual a 2.5
podemos obtener cada uno de los valores
de y por lo tanto cuál es la constante
de proporcionalidad
es 2.5 nos vemos en otro vídeo